les jeux de 20h l'émission bien connu de
notre chaîne étaient enregistrés ces
jours derniers à cholet dans le
maine-et-loire plusieurs personnalités
du spectacle participer à ces jeux dont
marcel grandpierre vous révèle les
coulisses
bonjour monsieur
enregistré en public les jeux de 20
heures que suivent chaque soir sur notre
chaîne de nombreux téléspectateurs
mobilise un important matériel et de
nombreux techniciens
au total une trentaine cameramen
électricien machinistes personnel de
réalisation disposant d'une mini
caravane de véhicules techniques car
magnétoscope pour l'enregistrement régie
mobile pour la réalisation car de
sonorisation et véhicules de servitude
après les répétitions du matin trois
jeux sont enregistrées par 12
successivement l'après midi de 13h30 à
19h jeu devant être diffusée la semaine
suivante sur les antennes nationales
chaque semaine enregistrement est
assurée par les moyens régionaux
ainsi retrouve-t-on à cholet faire 3 en
bretagne pays de loire
associé à fr3 lille chargée de la
sonorisation pour toutes les productions
réalisées dans la moitié nord du pays
soler une ville que connaît bien le
célèbre animateur de l'émission
c'est la deuxième fois que nous venons à
cholet et on va bientôt fêter notre
dixième anniversaire des missions et je
me rappelle la première fois que nous
étions venus on est à l'extérieur on a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de monde c'était
devant le syndicat d'initiative et on
avait été très très bien reçus par la
municipalité ce qui veut dire que nous
allons renouveler
voilà notre venue c'est avec beaucoup de
plaisir que ça m'a choqué des jeux qui
attire toujours les foules
bah oui vous avez jugé vous avez vu on a
à peu près de 1000 personnes aujourd'hui
donc je pense que c'est un succès
comment trouvez-vous le public de cholet
très bien très très bien très jeune
dynamique sympa cette fois le juge
arbitre m capello avait pour invités et
christian marin en tournée à cholet
julie bataille et j'aurai mon invité qui
pose les questions auxquelles doivent
répondre les candidats côté variété des
artistes de paris parmi lesquels faire
le client venu avec son dernier tube
voilà ici jeudi